I have been very critical of Alexandria
Acacio cortez when she doesn't know
stuff or when she says things that don't
make sense and I've actually been so
critical of her that people in the
audience have written to me and they
said David you're not being fair to her
even if she's not an expert on every
issue she has the right ideas and we
should support her because she will
learn by doing so my point in preface
ngosource an irrational knee-jerk
defender of Alexandria cassio Cortez if
anything I'm the opposite I've been
critical where I feel she deserves
criticism she is now being slammed
completely unfairly as some articles
have put it for quote banning the press
from her events the truth is that what
Alexandria Acacio courts has did is hold
some town halls in New York that were
open to the public but media was not
allowed in this is part of a listening
tour that she did in the Bronx and
queens that's where she's running and
she's being slammed for banning the
press she's being completely pillaged
for lack of transparency and these
criticisms I hate to break it to you are
completely ridiculous and absolutely
fabricated her response on Twitter to
this controversy was to say that quote
our community is 50% immigrant folks are
victims of domestic violence trafficking
and have personal medical issues this
town-hall was designed for residents to
feel safe discussing sensitive issues in
a threatening political time we
indicated previously that it would be
closed to press this is a stupid reason
to criticize her if you want to go after
Alexandria Acacio Cortes because she
said silly things about the unemployment
rate go ahead and do it if you want to
critique her because she seems confused
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
if that's what you believe then go ahead
and critique her for that if you want to
even debate the merits of a listening
tour have that debate okay I have no
problem with that even if you want to
debate whether closing events to press
is a good or bad idea as a campaign
strategy have that conversation
but having events that are close to the
press is just not a story and you
devalue your criticisms when you say
that this is tantamount to banning of
the press or in any way censorship and
it is these angry irate people who are
crying wolf every single member of
Congress I think everyone if not almost
everyone has private fundraising events
there is no press scrutiny other than
general scrutiny of we would like to
know what it is that they are saying to
donors behind closed doors and of course
I also would like to know this is a town
hall for constituents and the press is
simply not guaranteed access to
everything Alexandria Acacio Cortez does
criticize ur where it matters where it
makes sense but this is simply dumb and
you know if you're outraged that a
candidate met with a donor in private ok
well let's let's talk about that if
you're outraged that an elected official
Grit gave a private speech somewhere
let's talk about that but this was not a
press conference and this is not even a
defense of her policies or her ideas
this is merely saying this is a
completely manufactured scandal you
don't have to allow press into
everything you do and it's perfectly
reasonable to meet with would be or
actual constituents without media in
there and it is a devaluing of the
criticisms of Alexandria Acacio cortes
to go after her for this yeah I mean if
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes never allowed
the media into her speaking engagements
then maybe we'd have something
approaching a scandal or if she allowed
MSNBC and Mother Jones into the room but
you know not Fox News and Breitbart okay
we could have that conversation we're
not approaching any of this stuff
there's just nothing here there's
nothing here and it is a total joke to
see people on the right but also even
some on the left fall for criticizing
her about this and there are plenty of
things about which Alexandria Acacio
Cortes should be criticized and I've
criticized her for some of those but the
fact that sometimes she meets with
constituents or would-be constituents
without the media there is simply not a
story